calabasas fight companion guest and  former ufc heavyweight matt mitrione  gave his exclusive ufc 277 fight  reaction to the thick boy fight news  team after the main card ended i thought  that uh brandon moreno looked really  good man uh he's aggressive he's very  efficient as far as striking goes um  i thought he had great distance on his  jabs very well prepared like he always  is uh so i don't think that was much of  a surprise then after that uh i think  that i really thought julianna finally  was going to win i thought she's going  to put on a hell of a show  and she did as far as her gall and her  grit but she got her ass beat pillow to  post that's tough everybody goes through  it i got my ass beat pillow to post by  ryan vader so i get it everybody's on  the bad side sometimes tonight just  wasn't her night or tonight was really  amanda nunez's night she looked great  she looked fantastic and she beat that  ass